a good old Super Bowl not only is it the
biggest sporting event of the year it's
also the biggest gambling day of the
year and football fans and non-fans
alike 200 million of them from around
the world will be putting down more than
3.8 billion dollars on hundreds of bets
too bad only a hundred million dollars
of those bets will be legal anyway while
most wagers are about your
run-of-the-mill game stats and outcomes
there's a whole other subculture of vets
that only bring three letters to mind
we're talking about bets like what color
will Katy Perry's hair be when the
halftime show starts how many times will
Giselle be shown on TV what color
gatorade will be dumped on the winning
coach how many times will deflated balls
be mentioned it's a controversy about
balls they're gonna be really hard like
steel balls will build belly checks
hoodie have sleeves will Punxsutawney
Phil see a shadow and will the Patriots
win the Super Bowl what will there be
another wardrobe malfunction during the
halftime show odds are 20 to 21 that
there might be another Nipplegate in
case you're itching to know how long
will it take idina menzel to sing the
national anthem will she omit at least
one word while singing it and will
Marshawn Lynch grab his crotch once
again after scoring a touchdown yep
millions of people betting millions of
dollars on crotch grabbing let's hope he
doesn't disappoint there you have it
some of the most ridiculous and a music
bets millions will be wagering on for
Super Bowl 49 what's your money on